the chicky science show clips
so first then what is the protein
folding problem well when i normally
talk about proteins on this channel i
typically just draw a circle and write
the protein's name inside however
proteins don't look like that
proteins come in all different shapes
and sizes and it can be said that the
final structure of a protein can
determine what that protein's function
is for example my favorite protein p53
has a region that enables it to bind dna
that has a dna binding domain and so if
another protein also had the same dna
binding domain i would also go maybe
it's going to bind to dna but that's the
final structure of a protein all
proteins are composed of a series of
building blocks referred to as amino
acids there are 20 different amino acids
and the sequence of those amino acids
dictates the final structure of a
protein so the protein folding problem
seeks to understand how the sequence of
amino acids enables the production of
the 3d structure of a protein so the
protein folding problem is under the
assumption that all the information for
folding the individual amino acids
otherwise referred to as the residues is
actually in the amino acid sequence and
this assumption was proved
experimentally by christian athenson in
a very nice series of experiments where
he nicely demonstrates that all the
information for folding residues is in
the amino acid sequence and this is well
summarized in this figure here so the
protein that he was looking at is called
ribonuclease and to form the final 3d
structure of ribonuclease there are four
bonds that are really important and as i
failed to mention earlier it's the
formation of a variety of different
bonds between these different amino
acids that actually enables these 3d
structures of proteins to form so what
he did with this ribonuclease is that he
added chemicals in this case urea and
mecaptu recaptuno that caused these
bonds to break which you can see here
and this caused the structure of the
protein to unravel by then removing this
urea and re-oxidizing the solution the
protein structure was able to reform as
the conditions now enabled these
disulfide bonds to reform also allowing
the structure to reform and restoring
the activity of the ribonuclease
however if you change the order of a
fence such that you re-oxidize the
solution before urea is removed then the
protein incorrectly folds however this
can be restored by adding a reducing
agent that then enables the native
structure of the protein to be formed
with the correct bonds forming between
the amino acids and so effectively what
all of this does prove is that all of
the information that we need is in the
amino acid sequence and so the question
then is how hence the protein farting
problem so what do we know well we know
that there are different forces that are
driving a protein into its 3d folded
structure and the final structure often
referred to as the native structure has
the lowest free energy and so one way of
kind of envisioning how this process
works this folding process is the
protein folding funnel whereby you can
see there's different roots of folding
that result in the final protein
structure and also suggests that the
order in which the protein starts to
fold is also important for achieving the
native states so what are these
different forces that drive a protein to
fold well there are a variety of
different forces that come into play but
one thing i want to mention is the
importance of the type of amino acid
that's present in the sequence
different amino acids have different
so-called r groups that contain
different atoms and this gives the amino
acids individual different properties so
some amino acids have a positive charge
whilst others have a negative charge and
some have no charge at all well that's
never really quite true and so as an
example an amino acid with a positive
charge may be forming interactions with
another amino acid with a negative
charge but these two amino acids don't
have to be adjacent in the amino acid
sequence they could be much farther
apart but due to the 3d confirmation of
the final protein they could be now in
close proximity another thing that is
worth mentioning is that we understand
protein folding by using the different
levels of protein organization so
starting with the amino acid sequence
that is often referred to as the primary
structure and this final structure here
of the 3d folded protein is referred to
as the tertiary structure
and so in between the primary structure
the sequence and the tertiary structure
the final 3d structure of the protein
are you guessed it secondary structures
the two main secondary structures are
beta strands and alpha helices
and it's understood that the series of
different strands and helices within the
secondary structure make up the tertiary
structure so actually if we take a
closer look at this tertiary structure
here we can actually see that it's made
up of these different helices these
alpha helices and these different beta
strands the the ones that look like
arrows and it turns out that different
amino acids have different propensities
of forming either beta strands or alpha
helices and so already we've got some
information about amino acid sequence
and what the secondary structure could
be but looking at different amino acids
propensities of forming beta sheets or
alpha helices is nowhere near sufficient
to be able to create a 3d final
structure of a protein we need a lot
more information and one really valuable
bit of information comes from the use of
evolutionary covariation data now that
may sound complicated
but we'll get to it basically this
approach uses the power of comparing the
protein sequence to the same protein
sequence found in different organisms
for example mice rats snakes dogs cats
whales
you get my point and you take the same
sequences from these different organisms
and you form multiple sequence
alignments you see which amino acids are
the same or different in the different
species
now this is really important for
identifying amino acids that are really
important in the folding process and so
if we go back to that example i
mentioned earlier about having a
positively charged amino acid and a
negatively charged one that are forming
an interaction in 3d space that's
important for the final structure of a
protein i can generate a hypothetical
example to try and explain to you the
importance of this evolutionary
covariation data
so in this example sequence
let's say we've got nine amino acids
here and one of them is this positively
charged amino acid so it could be lysine
and one of them is negatively charged so
it could be glutamate and let's just
assume for simplicity that the rest of
the amino acids are glycine
okay
so we've got this positively charged
amino acid and we've got this negatively
charged one now let's compare this
sequence to these different species so
we can see in this case that the dog
also has the same positive and negative
charged amino acid it's got that lysine
and glutamate and it's also present in
the whale but if we look at the cats the
cat actually has them switched around
it's got the negatively charged amino
acid first and the positively charged
one seconds and what you might notice as
well is that we don't seem to have any
species that have two positive amino
acids and either those positions or two
negative amino acids and either those
positions
suggesting that those two residues show
evolutionary covariation if one of them
changes the other one has to change to
maintain an interaction between those
two positions in the final 3d structure